Marvel's newest round of infinity war
toys have once again revealed perhaps a
bit too much about an upcoming movie in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe in case
you don't remember thor ragnarok saw the
Odinson lose his right eye in a battle
with his villainous sister hella the
goddess of death while losing an eye
barely inconvenienced the god of thunder
in combat it did mangle his look leaving
the hero bruised and battered and shorn
of his locks by the end of Ragnarok
where infinity war picks up Hasbro's
assortment of infinity war toys as well
as Funko's bobbleheads have made it
perfectly clear that thor doesn't lose
his eye permanently in fact he seems to
get it back in time for whatever big
battle the Avengers have against Thanos
but a few toys tell a slightly larger
story Paz bros Marvel Legends 3-pack
gives us a Thor with an eyepatch hanging
out with rocket and a teenaged Groot a
trio that's repeated in the Lego set and
hot toys teaser photos for their own
infinity war action figures a later wave
of Marvel Legends includes a second Thor
this time with two working eyes and a
fancy new axe with a handle made of
Groot
new cos baby figures from Hot Toys also
appear to show the full evolution and
Thor status quo fixing a setback the
character suffered in his most recent
solo movie if they do indeed reflect the
events of infinity war the two Thor
figures seem to tell a story of personal
growth and triumph for the mythical
Asgardian fighter the first figure shows
Thor with an eyepatch charging himself
up for combat Dragonball Z style he
still sports the scars of his battle
with hella with only one lightning
charge died visible all is as expected
the second figure introduces a two-eyed
Thor with new armor and a new weapon
scarring around the figures right eye is
consistent with the damage hella cost
with one big difference the eyeball is
back suggesting that the god of thunder
is going to regenerate his eye as a part
of the push against Thanos while
audiences have seen Thor spontaneously
generate magical armor around his body
before we've never seen him regrow an
actual body part if all of this turns
out to be true it begs the question why
hasn't Miri grown as
err life is about it's about growth it's
about change previously a toy called the
Hulk out Hulkbuster seemed to confirm a
major moment from the upcoming superhero
movie revealing that Bruce Banner will
wear one of Tony Stark's Hulkbuster Iron
Man suits before going green inside it
bursting out of the armor like a
vengeful angry nesting doll Wow however
it's worth noting that these tie-in
products aren't always on the money with
occasional liberties being taken with
the story for the sake of making a
kick-ass toy previous reports that a
lego set had revealed Thor to be using
the comic book weapon yarn Bjorn an
infinity war turned out to be not quite
accurate it was later confirmed that
Thor's weapon in the movie would be an
axe called Stormbreaker so as fun as it
is and as accurate as it might end up
being it's still worth taking all of
this toy sourced information with a
hefty abundance of salt we'll be able to
see for ourselves what happens to Thor
in adventures infinity war when the
movie launches in theaters worldwide on
April 27th thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to
[Music]